well like so many parents you probably
still have a ton of questions
about distance learning especially if
your student is one of the thousands in
a magnet
or cta program well you can get some of
those questions answered
later today hector mejia is live near
downtown las vegas
with the details tell us more hector
hey there sherry good morning well so
many unknowns during a pandemic there's
a virtual meeting today for parents who
have kids in magnet or cta programs
and principals including the one from
rancho high school here are joining that
meeting which is taking place on
facebook
for the clark county school district the
new virtual academic year starts in a
week and a half so time is running out
magnet and cta programs give students a
boost preparing them for careers after
high school
here at rancho for example they offer
programs in pre-med
aviation and aerospace engineering just
to paint a picture
it has a new different academic year
approaches many parents still worry
about how those programs are supposed to
work out during the pandemic
so yesterday superintendent dr jesus jar
and trustee deanna wright logged on to a
virtual town hall
and addressed worries about distance
learning
i don't expect and i don't think anybody
does expects that kids will be on the
computer for six hours and 11 minutes
there will be an opportunity for
independent work as well
small group instruction
one of the many concerns for parents is
keeping their kids engaged in front of a
computer screen
the district is setting up a learning
hotline for students who may be
struggling once school starts that phone
number will go live on the first day of
school
on august 24th and will be available
monday through friday
the phone number is posted on our
website just go over to eight news now
dot com and as far as the virtual
meeting goes
it starts at four in the afternoon and
again it's taking place on facebook
on the ccsd parents facebook page
reporting live outside rancho high
school hector mejia
8 news now